today's topic Justin Bieber now if you
aren't aware there are some allegations
of inappropriate behavior that happened
with Justin Bieber makes me somebody got
on Twitter and basically said that
Justin did this and that to me I know
Hotel Wow while he was out South I know
Justin Bieber came out right afterwards
and basically provided receipts to say
it's impossible because I was my
girlfriend the whole time as well as
friends I have Hotel receipts thing at
different spots so what you're saying is
not true no I don't want to spend too
much time on Justin Bieber specifically
you don't think that we should believe
her [ __ ] if you don't get your corny
ass out of here right now
Kathie Lee said while I do believe that
all of these kinds of things should be
taken seriously to some degree fine I
find it pretty crazy that one person
from an anonymous account can get on
Twitter make an allegation and all of a
sudden everyone has to answer for it
does everyone else not see how crazy
that is it's an anonymous account you
just make a figure he had to prove and
have the receipt for anonymous account
this is why it's dangerous and we've
been saying we had a lot of flat because
of that you know all your just you know
Weinstein's apologist and it's not know
it can become very dangerous and there
you go an anonymous account thank God he
had a thief what if you actually knew
this person here's the thing right it's
just to me strikes me as crazy that
we're all gonna retweet Justin just have
you seen this answer for this like man
that's annoying that's really annoying
it's not just annoying it's like all
these people questioning your character
and if you get enough of these and all
those people are like well what does he
have in this closet there seems to where
there's smoke there's fire
the doubt is already fit it's already
put here's even though we have you see
people are gonna watch them differently
here's a problem with whether there's a
smoke there's fire sometimes when you
get to certain levels it's also true
that you're constantly in the kitchen
there's constantly smoke around you
because of how big and famous you are
you're always around that kind of heat
in that kind of predation I've seen
accounts of women saying I'm gonna do
what I can to get that money
that's a real thing out there as well
and sometimes people just want to do it
for attention how many cases do we have
to see on news where a girl gets has to
overturn a judge's verdict
Greg I was sent to jail and she said I
did it because I didn't want my
boyfriend to find out I was with another
dude or whatever crazy stories but
immediately because there's an
accusation there's always some element
of guilt that subscribed and now we're
talking about it just on Twitter so now
he's good working with Twitter and with
authorities to basically go after the
person who went after him and I think
yeah good okay good and they should pay
a whole life and I would say the flip
sides I also understand that people are
afraid to come forward because of people
have power and no one believes them and
I understand that I'm not saying that
this person is inherently a liar but
their statements should stand through
the court of law or else if we're just
gonna go on the court of public opinion
with very little to no evidence that is
things that's the danger of it I'm not
gonna just run off Twitter and be like
yeah this is true yo you had the biggest
pop star in the world replying to an
anonymous Twitter account how crazy is
that have you the news picked it up and
they ran with the headline and I'm like
what am i watching an anonymous Twitter
account it's really exactly like if the
news went oh in other news
someone said that that's exactly what
this is you see how dumb it sounds
someone said that that person did that
based on he says she said it's messed up
it's very dangerous it's very dangerous
and as someone who's been accused of a
weird situation either in the past and
then it was disproven shortly after it's
a frustrating thing to be accused
unjustly it's super frustrating but so I
can empathize with women who are going
through these situations and who are
really victimized and I feel bad and I
want us to have all the services that
you can help you but I'm not gonna go on
this believe women nonsense this is why
I don't do that I don't subscribe to
those kind of ideas I just want to make
this short video to discuss this topic
but let us know what you guys think in
the comments below we want to hear your
thoughts
[Music]